welcome to another episode of not too
deep I'm your host grace Helbig we have
a repeat guest but just an all-around
wonderful human being with us today an
actress a comedian an actual
professional dancer and an all-around
just excellent human being Nikki Glaser
is back with us on this episode of not
too deep and you know what we found out
a lot about threesomes this episode I
don't want to spoil anything but you
know listen and watch all the way
through to the end because it's somehow
it aspirationally ended with the idea of
wanting a threesome this episode of not
too deep is brought to you by our
buddies at Squarespace who want you to
know that you can turn your great idea
into a reality with Squarespace
Squarespace makes it easier than ever to
launch your passion project whether
you're showcasing your work or selling
products of any kind with beautiful
templates and the ability to customize
just about anything you can easily make
a beautiful website yourself and if you
do get stuck Squarespace is 24/7
award-winning customer support is there
to help so head to squarespace.com slash
grace for your free trial and when
you're ready to launch use the offer
code grace to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain welcome
back I'm so excited that you're here
having me back I so I was just tell you
I'm super obsessed with your Sirius XM
show you uh with Nikki Glaser thank you
um and I only got recently introduced to
it like in the last two months I think
and it is I get tired doing two podcasts
like once a week and you do two hours
every day yeah two hours every more
Monday through Thursday yeah and you've
been doing it for a full year it's
coming up on a year now yeah okay how
was that been cuz that just hearing this
makes me tired yeah I don't know I we're
always like a muscle that you've
exercised you know the same thing I like
doing a podcast I used to do podcasts
all the time like once weekly ones and
it felt like a chore most of the time
yeah it was a
very overwhelming at times but this is
just every morning it like has to be
yeah like it's just I have to show up
it's not even I like have a boss I feel
like I'm not making myself do it and I
feel like when you do your own podcast
it always feels like you got to do it
you're so motivating and this actually
gives you actually routine and structure
yeah we're depending on me a lot maybe
that's some jealous oh that I crave
control yeah people you have to show up
for yeah legalities and which have to be
fulfilled I almost like that I just it's
the first time in my life as a adult
having like a regular gig like they show
up to everyday I mean I've had shows
before in head but for a year solid like
my shows have always been canceled
before they made it a whole year so I've
never been like every day in the office
for a whole year yeah I like the
consistency of it and it's just it's
good to be talked like there's there's
no other place where I can talk so much
and get so good at broadcasting yeah but
also the coolest thing about it is how
candid you can be because I think that's
what really when I first started
listening to it I was like holy [ __ ] I'm
just talking about everything and
anything that's in her head or in her
co-hosts or guests head and they're
really not holding back and it must be
nice to have that freedom to be able to
kind of like exercise those thoughts
yeah and also it must be a little I want
to ask like about have there been shows
that you regret revealing so much cuz
you guys [ __ ] go there yeah and it's
great because you get to know you very
quickly very you know what is wrong with
me though it's I think there's probably
a therapy in it there's no there's and
I'm like not seeing a therapist right
now so it's really about like now's the
time to start listening to my show
because once I get a therapist she's
gonna set better boundaries for me with
what I say on air but right now I have
no one checking me and I need to get it
out and there you know what I like about
it is that it's live so once I say it
it's done and it's out there when I do
the cod cast I tend to reveal more
because I know the thing I can always
take it out later which I don't and then
I just say more and and then it's worse
so I've had more backlash and more
residual bad things happen in
relationships because of things I've
said
Podcast more than the live show every
day and I kind of went into it having to
be like Nicky what are you gonna save
what is sacred to you and I was I
decided nothing and so because I really
relate to it because I'm at an age I'm
33 now or I'm like I suck it like I've
been very reserved and how much I say
about like my personal experiences in my
life and I at this point don't care to
be that reserved because there's some
sort of relatability and there's some
sort of like I don't know there's just a
niceness and hearing someone else is
going through something as ridiculous if
not more ridiculous than something
you've been through and so that
candidness is just refreshing to me even
if it takes you like yes yes that's
great because there's this whole stigma
that when you're like a blonde woman and
you say you're a hot mess that people
like you're not really a hot mess like
let me tell you the ways gross it gets
and the thing is grace like I do hold
back something you do so it's like it
gets grosser and I want everyone to know
that whatever you think like I've said
what I'm capable of how gross it gets
this there's things I were talking I was
like okay I do hold that back because
there I think about the same things like
when I hear women talk so candidly about
things that I'm like well we kind of
can't believe she's admitting that it's
always such a relief it is nothing I've
never felt judgment on them I've never
lived for Rose I've never felt yeah I've
never felt like they're doing something
wrong and where I ever felt embarrassed
for them I've just been like this is the
strongest woman I've ever heard I
there's something very very admire about
this well you know what it's I had in um
who was it Paris Hilton walked into
studio one day it was amazing I'm gonna
get into your Instagram story which I'm
obsessed with yeah thank you
I saw this on your story of it yeah she
we got her in studios she wasn't even
like planning on being a guest I just
likes are in the hallway and I was like
oh my god that's Paris I loved it
because I felt like she you know you is
like someone
you're like closest and maybe looking
too so if you blur your eyes across the
room like I could be like she was when
she was like fresh on the scene I was
like young and like I could have like I
could have gotten there you know and I
couldn't do like a good impression she's
just like that's that's hot like I was I
was always like kind of into her and so
I saw her I'm like I didn't even know
she was gonna be here today like she's
walking into Andy Cohen's studio which
is right across the like right next
stars and said and I'm freaking out and
then we grabbed her and she came in and
or no we like we're texting the talent
department trying to get like can we get
her for a sec because she just say hi
can she get a picture with me like I'm
just a huge fan and and she was so cool
she can't she wanted to come in right
away because she saw I was like freaking
out and she was like we'll be back babe
and then she left she came back and like
we thought she was just gonna be in for
a couple minutes and she stayed the
whole segment till the end she was just
like so chill and just really I could
tell that I didn't want to push it too
hard but I could I could tell that I I
could have brought down with her pretty
hard and because she was more open than
I thought she would be and I just like
in the moment I had to be like what do I
want to know about her Paris Hilton like
I was like trying to think we're in one
break and I was like I know she's
probably gonna come in and I was like
she's just so unabashedly like I'm hot
and I'm putting my body out there and
I'm like I know I'm hot and like I just
am not comfortable with that and I
admire it I secretly wish I were as
comfortable with it like that and so I
asked her I was just like because this
is the thing that I can like talk about
my vagina and talk about how gross my
eating habits have been and currently
are and like reveal things that are so
embarrassing but like for me to post a
picture that's like I'm feeling myself
like they do like Emily Ratajkowski like
when they're just I'm sex you are sexy
and but the thing is grace you're so sex
like you could do those photos and carry
it and people would be like what and you
do sometimes like you see it come out
with you I've seen it you're sneaky set
big time I literally sit back and look
at those photos and oh god what the [ __ ]
did I just post I hate myself for it
this is
value that I want those girls don't
think that way and that's what I was
like what how do you not think that way
how do you not worry that people cuz I
go Paris if I were you I would post a
picture and be like there's no joke
there's nothing like sincere there's no
fake like thank you to my makeup team
it's just like I'm hot like like I would
my biggest fear would be like people
going like Paris things she's so hot and
she was just like yeah that like
probably happens and I don't care like I
just ah my brain has never worked that
way and I was like oh just wired
differently but that to me is so
embarrassing oh yeah and I like admire
that I don't I have too many wires I
think in my brain I think I overanalyze
and things that like other people
wouldn't Paris Hilton for you know ipso
facto that she doesn't care
whereas I could pretend I don't care but
that's just more effort to actually
cover up the caring that's still
happening underneath the surface at the
bottom there's care and there's like my
biggest fear is that peep
I picture like there are certain people
I picture screenshotting me and say hey
to their friends and having a text
exchange about how ridiculous I think it
is I know a couple people in my life
that will take this and make me feel
like if I can imagine them looking at
this photo that's too much for me to
post this photo but she does that in the
world mocks her for it like people mock
her and do the same that's part of her
brand I think is and I but but it she's
she can be here okay I will say please I
care what people think about her more
does she care so much if she's the
greatest actress of all time maybe who
knows I don't know I mean she could be
Andy Kaufman and everyone right now and
we don't know but like when you put that
much effort into your looks and like
looking hot do you care so much or
putting that out there and being like I
don't care what they think or if people
think I think I'm cool do you not care I
think she doesn't know any other way
yeah I think I've only known how to be a
tomboy trash monster and
to put effort into DTM yeah to be
actually like putting money and value
into my looks is unfamiliar to me
whereas her dressing the way I would
dress on a normal day is probably
radically unfamiliar and you know
therefore uncomfortable and like doesn't
compute for her at all at least that's
the way I like to rationalize like hey
teach their own but I will say that in
terms of you putting yourself out there
and a sexy fun cool admiral way you did
Dancing with the Stars yes and like talk
about having to be in your actual body
for that it was just an excuse to look
beat
take take being sexy and like like a
show woman seriously and I didn't have
to go I'm a jokey I got to lick on be
sincere about this ridiculous thing but
also Maximilian I listen to you on part
of Joe Rogan's podcast talk about it and
I was like I get that I would never have
said yes so I give you so much respect
for saying yes and doing something that
is so wildly outside of your comfort
zone and when you were describing like I
dancing is not what I'm built for so I
may as well just take a chance and do it
and you really liked honestly did it you
didn't like come out as the jokey girl
like you came out like fully in yourself
and like feeling yourself that I was
like screaming at my TV the night that
you were so sweet about it your support
meant a lot to me you know I see myself
at that and that's like very very cool
to be like I'm gonna take this weird
arbitrary cliche TV risk situation and
that show is so [ __ ] intense oh my
god it's the greatest thing I've really
I loved it so much grace yeah I'm dying
to go back I know that you're starting
the fake campaign for the loser series
is sincere I thought it was maybe gonna
wear off like this feeling of like I
went back in right but I loved it so
much and and my journey is not done that
show I like I hope your talking head
interviews are already so sissing isn't
I refuse to live in a world where I
cannot go on the dancing with stars
again yeah just I don't wanna like it
makes me so it feels like I suffered the
loss of being kicked off that show in
that journey ending sure like a death
like I was like I can't do this
well cuz you know it's I can't imagine
the whirlwind that it is so you don't
get a chance to process it and then it's
taken away from you I think you're like
I'm not in it I haven't even started the
process being here you know take it away
from me first show like I go home first
like it just first of all I didn't I
didn't think I was gonna go far in the
show I've made that very clear a million
times and even when I signed up when I
was like it the only thing I was like
the only thing I want is to not get
kicked out first and there's just no way
I will like I I will figure out a way to
be entertaining enough even if I'm the
worst dancer on the show which I wasn't
but even if I am I'll still they'll want
me around because I'll be fine I'm right
and you weren't the worst dancer and I
was neither fun I guess nor a good
dancer and that's what is crushed me but
no it's not that because it's based on a
voting system of people that are not
your core demo yeah so blame middle
America your effort it's not your
talents it's literally something that is
ridiculously outside of your actual
control it is but even that like
realizing that whether it was the
network that decided to let me go or
they all hit that asterisk that it's
like producers have final say whenever
the vote is yeah I don't even know if
it's like that on that show cuz I really
didn't look into the holy gala t of it
but even no matter what it was there was
something someone didn't want me around
appreciate did not feel good but I also
think just optimistically speaking that
show is so torturous on a human body
because how many hours a day are you
dreaming I would be I was so injured
when I performed yeah I know you had
like a full shoulder industry an
industry injury when it was like the day
that you were supposed to perform it was
so insane how injured I was I look back
and I'm like oh my god if I would have
continued I would have just become I
would have just numbed it out with pain
stuff but that didn't mean then you'd
have irreversible damage what and I
would be like would what's the value
here it wouldn't matter how many hours a
day were you training for a day for a
day and that was not enough I was like I
need more I want to be doing this
full-time like that's insane to me
because you need so many breaks during
it and towards the end you're like
can't even take breaks now and you just
need more and more time and I was I was
having to learn three dances by the time
we went to this like we I had already
learned two and a half dances I got
injured from working on my third dance
which I was like I didn't even need to
learn that at all and I got like injured
from like a dumb lifts like these two
guys just lifted me and we were just
like you know it was the dumbest thing
where you get injured but like these two
like hot Russian dudes on that side of
me aris was like lift me and I am NOT a
dancer so my dance partner Gleb was
instructing them on how to lift me and
he didn't like I don't know that you're
supposed to like brace when I was just
like and then I was rude so yeah I would
but people are dancing a broken foots on
that show like it is brutal and it but
it was so fun to like just work a
literal different muscle of like a
physical feat like it was kind of I mean
you're sporty yeah I like to run but I
that's the thing I'm so not coordinated
in terms of rhythm in that way I've
tried to do a couple like we've had
choreographers come on shows with mamrie
and I and spend a half hour with me and
then we have to resign - I'll be the one
that is purposefully off rhythm in this
dance but it's really like I'm genuinely
trying to pick up the numbers and the
counts of everything and I just I don't
have that mind-body connection in that
regard I went to like a Zumba fitness
class one time and I literally was like
a scarecrow in the back of the room just
being like I'm ruining it for everyone
else because I I can't even do a four
count like it is so it's humiliating and
that's the way I I mean gleb was my
partner that's a lot like did you know
this is your dad no
looks like I get there and I meet him
and he I walk in the room and he's like
oh this girl looks like she like I look
like maybe I kept some s like yeah so
you're like okay
Arina maybe and he said I mean he told
me later on like right away to say oh
dear I don't think I've been the worst
answer he's ever been with and it sucks
and like it seemed like you guys had a
good time so yeah they did have a good
time it was just yeah I mean it keep in
touch now we do wear acts
like working on something together cuz I
just like I loved that show I loved
everyone I met on it was just like you
know when you work on a show and you
just get close to that it's also just
such an intensive environment that you
have no choice than to like just
freefall into it and then feel like whoa
I only have a few people in the world
that have experienced as intense of a
situation as me so we have this very
special connection about this thing even
other other stars in it like just even
going through that with them and meeting
them like I've made like lifelong
friends it really is the show is as
cliche as everything you hear I went to
a taping of it the season before because
they brought a bunch of social media
influencers into the audience and they
wouldn't let anyone use their phones
except for us
and we sat right behind what's the
female judge Carrie Ann Inaba yeah my
ex-boyfriend and I were sitting right
behind her and we decided that we were
just gonna look directly into camera and
smile the whole time and they came over
and politely told us that we weren't
allowed we're getting tweets being like
Grace and Chester right behind the judge
and they look like psycho staring
directly down the lens of a camera and
then they slowly just started shifting
the camera and go oh my god had a great
grandma of it so that's great but it was
so intense even just being there seeing
how the whole operation worked that I
mean I can't imagine dude when I got
kicked off that show I could not get my
life back together like get my bearings
you're literally claw machine so I got
eliminated at 7 p.m.
West Coast time and I had to be on Good
Morning America East Coast time the next
morning so you you get eliminated at
7:00 I had to be in a car at 7:30 I
didn't know I was being eliminated like
I had maybe if they go pack your bags
just in case yeah it's like when you go
on a group date and you everyone gets a
show and you watch them all packed their
bags by the front door in case one of
them gets eliminated tonight yeah I was
supposed to have that prepared and I
didn't realize and I didn't have an
outfit for Good Morning America like if
I move and so i before like right before
we go live i was like kind of sitting
around like thinking about like couldn't
go home tonight like no way don't let a
maggot of that weight I'm going home
tonight like oh this is looking good and
I'm texting my stylist being like can
you throw together it's really I don't
know what to do so they threw something
together and deliver it and that's all I
went to New York North I didn't have any
other
fact was I felt like claw machines like
I felt like they just spit me back in
New York and then I woke up like off the
jet and we had to go right to Good
Morning America we didn't sleep and I
was just like what's happening and then
afterwards and then my dance partner
leaves and goes back to LA and I'm just
like in New York New York Saints saying
I'm like I don't have to dance for four
hours today what is my life like it just
I didn't know any the news what's going
on I didn't know the news like the
Cavanaugh trial happened and I was just
like I didn't I was kind of the hearing
about that again I'm like what happened
that oh I do believe women okay I did it
I was out of everything it was a bubble
and my friends I wasn't relating to my
friends anywhere I was so upset about it
I was trying to watch the show and I was
getting like PTSD because I'm like I
want to be there tweeting at them like
don't forget me like I just loved it so
much but uh and it's still very a part
of my life like I'm still friends with
so many of the people and like yeah I'm
going to the Dancing with the Stars live
tour next week it's that though it
finally comes to a close for me next
week because they're coming to New York
City and I'm going to like see them oh
you're from Melania for know they would
[Laughter]
that's amazing okay we're take a quick
break and when we get back I've so many
more questions to ask you about it's
just everything we'll be right back with
Nikki Glaser I'm not too deep guess what
grace is it happening again it's
happening again our buddies are back
okay Squarespace is sponsoring this
episode of not too deep turn your dream
into a reality with Squarespace they
make it easier than ever to launch your
passion project whether you're looking
to start a new business showcase your
work published content sell products and
more Squarespace is the tool for you
they have beautiful templates created by
world-class designers and the ability to
customize just about anything with a few
clicks you can
easily make a beautiful website all by
yourself Squarespace is powerful
ecommerce functionality lets you sell
anything online and analytics help you
grow your site in real time and guess
what
everything is optimized for mobile right
on the box there's nothing to patch or
upgrade ever buying domains is simple
and you'll get all the help you need
with Squarespace is 24/7 award-winning
customer support they empower millions
of people from designers lawyers artists
gamers restaurants gyms jacks
that's right I use Squarespace guys it
works great I know I talk about them all
the time
it's our only talking point but I mean
it actually is a really great way to
like make a website we genuinely
authentically use them and they're very
very helpful so turn your great ideas
into something real head to
squarespace.com such grace for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use the offer code grace to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain again that squarespace.com such
grace offer code grace I am so excited
why is that do you feel desperate and
lonely how did you know my favorite two
emotions I also feel that way that this
episode of not too deep is sponsored by
something that will cure those feelings
it's okay Cupid oh thank goodness
yeah it's the only dating app that finds
you someone based on who you are and
what you're into that's good because you
don't want to date somebody who's not
into what you're not into been there
done that right it's a waste of time
yeah but OkCupid the OkCupid dating app
asks you fun and meaningful questions
that matter to you so you can be seen by
the people who are going to be into you
we're talking about super specific
questions like do you prefer to share
food yeah are you close to your family
do you like going clubbing does your
family like going clubbing do you have a
passport I'd prefer not to answer the
last one are you are you wanted by the
FBI
you see tons of answers that will
eventually lead the great conversation
and great dates of people who feel the
same way you do yeah you can tell people
about your favorite album your last
great trip your favorite podcast maybe
the greatest conversation starter there
ever was and then you can just let the
love roll in on the OkCupid app if
you're looking for a person to join you
for a long walk on the beach or a short
walk to the pool bar they're waiting for
you on the OkCupid
so start the new year by meeting someone
who's into what you're into on the
OkCupid app download the free OkCupid up
and find your next great date today
Nikki Glaser I think I saw when you got
flown to the Today Show was they show
the night after Good Morning America
yeah
they you had to roast the host I didn't
have to but I wanted to well I was
preparing for them to say something so I
the first night that I did an someone
starts a premiere yeah they gave me low
scores they were pretty mean to me and
it was just like out of nowhere and it
just felt like pointed why like I just
completed a dance I'm not a good dancer
I never said I was it wasn't that kind
of impressive a little bit to be so mean
the first night and then that so the
next night I was like but do you think
that they were on guard because you were
the comedian coming in that they were
like produced to be a little bit sharper
to maybe yeah I had to be like on guard
that you might roast them so they wanted
to get out of the gate in front of you
you're probably right but I just wanted
to be taken so building on the realities
like I was just trying to be as like
Disney as possible cuz I wanted to
follow the rules gracious to be there it
was so excited to be there I was like so
amazed that they even asked me like yeah
I was just it was a treat so I wanted to
play by their rules I wasn't gonna say
anything that was like racy which I
accidentally did and I didn't even mean
to even though I was trying to behave
myself but after they were mean to me on
that judge's table and I was like I need
to roast them back so I was like
tomorrow night when I know they're gonna
be mean to me again because my second
dance is the same dance as the first
dance it's all very very similar and
they hated me the first night I'm not
gonna get better to the second night
because I'm already so mad and in my
head and I don't even like the second
dance as much as the first dance so I'm
not gonna probably be as good and so I
performed the second dance and then they
loved it and I was like okay and now I
can't roast them but I think they caught
wind that I was gonna roast them because
if they would have been meat at all
they were like you bet dance last night
the dance controled you and tonight you
controlled the guy so I was like I just
felt like if
gonna be totally honest that dance well
that I just did was garbage oh no that
was the first night I was like okay I
got through it and there was some fun
things that I did the second night I was
like total garbage like that was I know
when I can dance but like they knew if
they if they hated my first dance
they hate it so I was like you're being
insincere right now you're being nice
because you know I'm about to go home
because you trashed me last night so
you're not gonna kick a horse when she's
down yeah so you're being nice and so I
couldn't roast them but I had all these
jokes planned and I was like that so
then when I got eliminated that night
and then I was like so immediately it's
the most humiliating thing that's ever
happened you know getting eliminated
first from a reality show you're just
like standing staring at the dance floor
hearing being like Nicky and Gleb
Nichkhun go up I know he's gonna say and
he was like Nicky and Gleb and I was
just like it's just humiliating and
there's like boys in the room there's
like there it was just like my my
ex-boyfriend was there watching me fail
my parents were there watching me fail
like I just couldn't get past the flick
first eliminated a loser and then I just
was like then then I got mad so then
afterwards I get my trailer and I'm like
it's [ __ ] it's not fair like and I
could have done this and I'm but you
know I'm like pacing around being a baby
because you just you're so embarrassed
that then you get angry also you're just
emotionally raw yeah yeah I was and like
it was just I went through the whole
spat it's like in front of my parents
are my trailer my ex-boyfriend my
producers from my radio show my Tom to
car my coat we're all piled in and I
walk in and they're all waiting for me
because I had to go through the press
line the losers press I think the worst
[ __ ] thing oh it's like let's just
squeeze out every piece of terrible
emotion that you could possibly have
right now yeah we just want to
continuously break you down yeah and
everyone having to hug everyone and be
like we're gonna miss you and I'm like
you guys are all like not gonna get [ __ ]
I'm a cog in a machine yeah and thank
you for a fake sentiments exactly walk
into the trailer nobody this isn't fair
and I have to like pack and I'm not
ready to I don't even know what I'm
wearing and I don't
like what am I gonna wash my face with
like they didn't even tell us and I'm
just like having this meltdown and then
there's I don't have a choice I have to
go to a Good Morning America so then I
get in the car and and glove is waiting
for me and he's like in his phone just
like kind of checked out cuz he's like
done he's like okay he's kind of he's
he's sad but he's also like good you
know like yeah it's he's done this so
many times that that's when you finally
everyone is at a breaking point even
when the show starts assuming it by the
end of it it is like everyone is so
tired and yeah all the time during a
show so when you finally get kicked off
there's a sense of relief and gloves
been through it so many times he's like
yeah whatever yeah so he's already in
this mode of like it's fun now we're now
we can have fun I can drink on the plane
like very very yes and I get in the car
and I'm just like really upset and and I
hadn't smoked pot for like a month and a
month at that point and I was like and I
needed it during the show and I just did
it because I couldn't remember dancing
supposedly yeah yeah remember my memory
was crap yeah it was like treating yeah
so then I get in the car and I'm like I
have a vape in like should i I'm like
should I just cuz because I keep being
sober in this video and then I was just
like I'm doing it and then I went from
being like [ __ ] this show and like I'm
not even gonna sleep if you're good
right you're gonna look like old and
like my hairs I haven't even walked by
early to my I've been in powdi baby mode
Allah no one's looking out for me I'm
alone I feel overwhelmed so I went from
that and Gleb is not in the mood for
that so I've already had couldn't really
voice that in the car and I was just
like kind of in my head like and it and
then I smoked a little pot and then I
was just like [ __ ] you have one last
performance
you get to go in good morning goddamn
America tomorrow you get to have an
interview alone with George
Stephanopoulos man Gleb now I get to
dance because I get to be interviewed
which I'm a pro that's running event a
backseat Club learn from the master so
then I started preparing that set like
yeah I was like okay I have one last
dance I'm gonna start I'm gonna start
writing jokes for that so I just really
like honed in on it and I like wrote a
bunch and I just tried to like own it
because I was like I'm gonna spin this
being the loser well you're getting just
a good thing the actual skill set that
you are strongest at should be like this
is the reason I was asked to be on the
show because I offer something different
and this is what I'm good I might not be
good at dance but I can see right
through all of you so here yeah and I
did it in a way that was still
respectful of the show because because
like I said I went back on and we'll
never say a bad thing about that show
very careful I honestly I don't really
have many bad things to say but I do
love that show and I respect it but the
judges if I ever get back on they I will
be mad like cuz now there's a beef yeah
they were not cool to me
they didn't like me they got in the arms
I hope this pushes forward the storyline
that gets you back on the show because I
think race a really interesting thing to
bring back people that actually have
dumped ssin yeah a Redemption series
everyone loves an underdog and everyone
loves to seesaw I have more in me I
really did is I got stuck with a bad
opening dance like salsa is not my
strong and I just and I got injured
there were so many things not to say
that that couldn't happen again but I
have I could go further but give her a
second chance if I'm voted off the first
on the losers season though then you
gotta retire I gotta be like don't don't
my god leave please leave this is I just
got my period after I got the last time
I got my period was on Dancing with the
Stars four months ago like like right no
okay I took so many pregnancy tests
Greece I was like can there be 18 Falls
pop-
when I took was the day before I got my
period which was four months after my
last period so I was like I'm either
four months pregnant I've hurt my body
to such a degree my friend goes girl you
haven't gotten your beard because you're
still holding on to Dancing with the
Stars like that egg I finally let it go
last week but I was like I am I'm
holding on to that so my body stopped I
mean mother nature's the greatest of all
time yes well talking about roasting
that's because I'm kind of like your ma
mo kind of situation do you like that
that's part of like your brand now or is
it feel a little daunting to be like I'm
the person that roasts people and now I
feel obligated to have to do this
constantly yeah I'm not good at it off
the cuff like I can think really mean
things but that doesn't mean that I
should say the things like I don't have
a joke wrapped around them yeah yeah
it's very it seems like a great skill to
be able to wrap it up in like a nice bow
about people but it also feels a little
daunting to be the person that people
look to to do that I'm good at roasting
because I'm good at writing jokes and
I'm good at working on writing jokes I'm
good at organizing a set and I'm good at
and I'm have a dark side that's why I'm
good at roasting and and I perform live
enough that I can like get in a
situation where you can't really prepare
for a roast like that out like you can't
create those elements beforehand to like
rehearse so it's just it's a very it's
something you have to be very present
just for like I've been on stage so many
times in life situations that I can I
can nail it but I'm not like a natural
lake like a row steeper Jeff Ross is
just so quick you're not a singer
exactly but you're right I get asked all
the time like on when I did good morning
America to announce the Dancing with the
Stars cast it gets a Good Morning
America early the morning the whole cast
they're all the dancers are it's chaos
and one of the producers come up comes
up to me like 10 minutes before we go
live yeah and they're like your question
cuz you're all gonna get a question
every person every stop that question
yeah yours is gonna be who are you gonna
roast the judge this year and what what
are you gonna say oh god and I was like
guys no I can't
and they're like what we can't change
the question it's in the prompter I was
like well I don't have an answer to this
because I don't want to be mean to the
judges because first of all I owe them
like like I don't want to like come off
and that's not who I am at all like a
roast and so it was like panic time and
I it's a very lesson and I was like okay
I can trust the judges but I can't go
after like Tom Bergeron so I had pulled
up a picture of Tom Bergeron because I
was like I know he can take it I'm
familiar with him enough yeah it's like
a funny guy
so I'm like looking at a picture of him
just ten minutes before being like what
does he look like what does he look like
and I'm like I'm the makeup guy goes he
kind of looks like Dustin Hoffman and I
was like oh you are brilliant it looks
like a low-rent Dustin Hoffman but
that's not the joke what is the joke
there's got to be a joke so I'm
scrambling just like Dustin Hoffman
meets blah blah doesn't have it what is
the UM and I said um he looks like it
just for men like the box of just for
men like I was like oh there's a just
for men jokes they're like I just saw
and then I went up to Bobby bones
another guy in the show that's like a
comedy guy and I walked it to him and I
was like and I watched a couple of you
around like what does happen and he was
like Men's Wearhouse or like yeah
menswear about Dustin Hoffman I was like
yes and then I went out there and like
was able but it was just the lat it was
the last minute combining the pieces to
come up with a host show but that's what
they do they always thinker like can you
just roast us real quick I'm like give
me like two weeks to write Joe yeah I
workshop them and like bring back my
final drafts yes yeah that's when I can
do it but yeah I don't like that do you
get that on the road a lot cuz you
you've been on the road like crazy
lately right
yeah because I will tell you I've
mentioned earlier I'm obsessed with your
Instagram story yes one of the most well
curated Instagram stories that I follow
well you I don't know how you do it all
day i watch yours and I'm just like I
think one selfie and I go oh this kiss
doesn't work and then I go at the end of
the day well really [ __ ] up another
day of creating content for the internet
but yours is so like I don't know where
you find me at times like be some like
yesterday I didn't do any of it and I
was like why was yesterday like what did
I do and I was like oh i had like
friends yesterday i had human
interaction
more like present with my wife yesterday
and I wasn't depressed or like generally
when I'm depressed I can't post but like
yeah I just at night I collects things
on reddit like interesting screenshots
of their and it's the one thing I don't
check into as much it's like my little
treat at the end of the day like I have
been on reddit for like five years so I
follow ones that I'm interested in and
like I get to check it out then the day
and then I screenshot things that I'm
like oh maybe I'll show people that so I
have like a little like folder of that
that I'll just sometimes dump but like
in terms of like it's just so much
easier to post on your story than it is
a real post like you just feel like if
someone's watching it they're choosing
to watch it I'm not just putting it in
their face so I feel a little less
guilty about my furniture
it's a like I can be like vain and be
like talking into my phone I'm just like
doing a story that is just so
self-serving yeah because I rationalize
that anyone watching it is choosing to
watch it yeah and whereas on the feed
like sometimes you're just like I don't
see that but like a story someone's
choosing to put themselves through this
oh no I like that you unabashedly talk
about how any comedian that tells you
their show is sold out it's just
actually bragging brag now and I want to
brag I'm just like I'm bragging yeah
because that's how you let people know
that you're killing it because when we
when people go yeah that girl's killing
it I go why do you know that what do you
think that and then I find out it's cuz
they're her Instagram yes well she's
showing you that she's killing it yeah
yeah yeah no that's the I think that's
the really fun interesting thing it's a
kind of unabashedly play that game even
though it's not even playing a game it's
just being like this is what I'm doing I
think there's something very cool or I
look really pretty in this mission so
happens to be fun understand my dancing
it was like a very hot photo and then
you'll post you just like post running
after two hours I feel like I don't want
to mislead anyone cuz I do use my
Instagram to like attract men you know
like guys when you posting on your story
you're like you're just making content
for your crush like one of my friends
said that recently I was like you're so
right literally all it is oh no that's
all it is
no that's exactly what it is there's no
to hang it's not for my mom it's not for
my friends I could give a [ __ ] watching
those guys see it it's just like a hit
of heroin it but it's so true
Instagram stories are just for crushes
it's just for crushes and I realize that
I'm like you're right it is so funny to
me that we like I could have 20,000
people watch something when I post and
all I care about is one one person yeah
and we're all like I mean that's I got
really mad at Instagram and then very
excited when they switch it over to that
you can see whoever you're following
watches your story all day instead of
just in that moment when you go back and
check your story that you wants to do
what they used to tell you what they
used to show you like here's the top if
people that you're following or watching
your story if you go back and check your
story in that moment if they've just
recently checked it'll tell you like
here's this person this person that just
watched your story just watch and so you
had to catch it in the moment of the
person that you want to watch your show
you're watching your story and now you
can actually kind of sit back and like
go back and check it later and they show
you all that that was a great move
Instagram thank you so much that is such
a good move like you would have to be
there for it yeah it's like continuously
check but now they watch I'm up to the
top yeah to let you know sometimes I
train and sorry I'm I'm like just maybe
he's not maybe is watching this but
Instagram doesn't know I like him so
they don't know to him to show me at the
top right so I'll go to his page to be
like Instagram my personal
[Applause]
scroll and look for his name like a fool
I got desperate dummy no things to do
okay what's happening this year for you
I'm gonna shoot a Netflix special that's
awesome that's why I'm on the road so
much it's just like building I'm getting
that going when do you want do you get
to choose where you shoot it yeah ever
like everything I think I'm doing it in
LA because I just want to put it's
cheaper to do things here and I just
want to like make it really cool and
there's so budget-wise I'm just like
okay let's do everything is cheap and
then like other stuff we do is super
cool cool and yeah I'm excited about it
because I haven't put out one in a
really long time and that'll be so and
just good enough like special it's like
it's the thing to do it's like it
changes your life it's there's so many
the world of stand-up is so insane to me
because now there's like a half hour
specials hour especially 15 minute
specials and it's just like I'm doing an
hour and I'm doing it's three and a half
minutes special to I would and it's for
Hulu got it it's great everyone is
competing against everyone else okay we
take one more break and then we have a
bunch of Twitter questions for you if
you would be so obliged
Quest's for answers so we'll be right
back with more Nikki Glaser or not
you're deep too deep is brought to you
by guess what me undies the Valentine's
Day is right around the corner rather
than spending all that money going out
to fancy restaurants why not just hang
out in your underwear courtesy of me
undies my mom is really proud of me for
saying that to a bunch of strangers
listening to a podcast made from the
coveted micro modal fabric which is
three times softer than cotton me undies
genuinely feels like heaven against your
skin men and women can each choose from
four different cuts all of which are
available in classic colors and
adventurous prints including new video
prints which release every Tuesday but
why stop there this year me Indies
launching their v-day prince and guess
what lounge pants and onesies y'all both
are made from the same micro modal
fabric as their undies and I will tell
you they do feel like heaven against
your skin
I was agnostic before I tried them and
now I'm fully subscribed to the Church
of me undies they have a great offer for
you our beautiful listeners first-time
purchasers get 15% off and free shipping
when you order me undies it's a
no-brainer get 15% off the most
comfortable undies you will ever put on
free shipping and 100% satisfaction
guarantee when you go to me undies calm
such grace
that's me undies comm slash grace okay
we're gonna get into some Twitter
questions before we do I'm gonna ask you
again the two questions I ask every
guest that comes on the podcast and the
first is who alive or dead would you
most want to throw cold spaghetti at oh
I mean it do I say the obvious I mean
like oh really like it is there someone
I mean probably Trump yeah yeah yeah I
mean as I see I just like his face comes
on at the gym and I just have to go like
this like I just don't want to see it
so probably him I'm with you the other
question I ask every guest is tell us
your worst pants [ __ ] story or close
call but you can only use three words or
small phrases so mine is college jogging
front lawn okay okay oh when was the
last time there's been like several
times really proud of you in an odd way
I mean it was like August mid August
2008 one of these slash pants shooting
stories I've ever heard it's just an
actual date and time
[Laughter]
two incredibly okay let's go into some
Twitter questions
someone says I love not safe on Comedy
Central is there a segment that missed
making it to the show
which for people that don't know not
safe was your show on Comedy Central
that was centered around the sex
basically yeah sex and dating but mostly
sex yeah and one thing we did that we
planned on airing but never aired
because we got cancelled but we had some
stuff like banked was I took a blow job
class with my mom whoa shop in Hollywood
and it was weird and funny and I think I
hear that footage yeah you don't get it
back I think it's just like probably
like come on I don't know where it is
but like it was a weird day I put myself
in situations on that show that I'm like
why did you do that I mean the show is
so wonderfully intense and you were on
it you were great on I was so
overwhelmed by you know a deer in
headlights how the buttons I should have
like maybe done some research before
yeah you know also I was going through a
recent breakup and the guy that I was on
the show with was friends with my ex and
I was just like oh dear I would like to
not talk about relationships no but you
guys put together so happy to have you
on that show it was a great team a great
system yeah proach your mom with that
segment idea I was just like mom you
have to like do this I'm like I like pay
for it you know I'm gonna like pay for
your life the rest of your life so just
like help me out here
are there any things that your parents
comment on that they're like Nicki
please don't ever do that again
or we wish you later on like when we
were talking about things we've set up
on shows and podcasts before like there
are things that I've said about my mom
that are like fresh wounds from like a
therapy session and then I like to lash
out on like air and you say something
that I'm like because my mom didn't do
this as a kid and I'm like that's not
for everyone to know Nicki and it's not
even for your mom to think about
like it's just it's just mean and and
I've regretted things like that but yeah
yeah and so there have been times like
that with her future where she's like
can you not that hurt me and in
retrospect I'm like I was such a like I
just said I ever - I was being selfish
like in that moment with my feelings
yeah and now I've learned like I can
apologize and like own it and be like
yeah I was not a good person then no I
think that's great I mean it still seems
like you have a great relationship with
your parents yeah that is it's really
good I'm lucky
this is pointed someone says how the
hell does she deal with Tom every single
day he's bland and boring need to know
her secret um let's not answer that one
because I disagree more with that person
he's just like someone who is one of the
funniest people I've ever met in my life
and I chose him for my co-host and he's
amazing they clearly care enough to make
a comment exactly that person knows that
Tom I'm guessing and is just trying to
make him sad because no one's ever
thought Tom's not funny no that's your
co-host on yeah yeah on you up yeah
since the iconic Roast of an Coulter
what other political figures would you
like to roast like a hot dog on a grill
I don't care no political figures I just
say I don't want to do I would never
like Michelle wolf doing the
Correspondents Dinner like roasting
those people who don't have senses of
humor about themselves which already
like Bruce Willis and Rob Lowe like the
people I've roasted are already take
themselves pretty seriously yeah and
that's part of the joke of it but that's
politically that no there's no winning
that I also feel like I mean so Twitter
just an open roasts 24 hours a day of
political people that it just feels like
what are you gonna say that no one's
ever said but yeah online about I
thought like roasts would be dead after
Michelle wolf like how everyone got so
offended by how and she was so great
like I just lost everything oh they're
over now if they can't take those jokes
it's over
yeah how am I supposed to go up and do
like actually illegal jokes because she
was playing by their rules and she did a
good job so but I was surprised that
they even did another roaster to that so
but yeah that's is there anyone that you
is there anyone that you
want to roast you know it like I went
into the roast being like oh I don't
mind like I can handle whatever they say
I didn't even think about it and then
you get called like ugly a couple times
in specific ways that you're just like
roasting everyone as well as like the
main person yeah it was like oh I know I
see that when I look in the mirror I
didn't know anyone else saw it and I
didn't think that and then you just
think about a writers room just staring
at a picture of your face cuz that's
literally what they do is they put your
face up and then they just look all day
well she kind of looks like oh and
Wilson he were more masculine like
whatever they're like pitching and
you're oh my god and then so there's
after the residually after the roast
like everyone kind of rolled their eyes
about Sarah Silverman saying that she
had a hard time at the roast of I forget
who was Justin Beiber James Franco and
she was like they called her old and she
was like it felt bad and everyone was
like when when but it's it really does
hurt it's actually yeah to be like
called things that you're like I didn't
think that I was that but no I guess I
am yeah everyone's laughing and it's one
thing to read it in like a youtube
comment consistently but to hear an
actual voice say it to your face and a
room of people erupt and laughter being
like wait we support this comment it's
like no yeah someone snow what's your
favorite thing to do when visiting st.
Louis um I love your friend yes yeah my
favorite thing to do is see my nephew
and my dogs that now live at home with
my parents
that's my just like you showed two dogs
and you gave them I gave my dogs away
yeah it's my parents and the most
responsible thing you could do is hard
to do that's on the road constantly it's
just like I wanted to have dogs forever
but the and I thought it would be really
hard to get rid of them yeah they were
gone I was like
I don't think I should have dogs do they
when you come back and visit them is
there a sense of weirdness or they like
she's back from war
no they forget that they don't forget
who I am but I am NOT their owner
anymore since June and it's January now
so it's been seven months of them not
living with me and so one of them might
my og like my first dog that I like we
got through it when we travel along
dealer he is like a teenager who's just
like you left me Mobley's like
rebellious and not listening to me he's
like kind of fat now like a little punk
he's just sharp mom and like that has no
respect for me none and where he used to
respect me he would do anything I said
so now we're both like not getting along
I'm kind of over it but then my dog
Marian who I got later is now living
with my parents and she still like loves
me and sleeps with me and stuff when I
come home and it feels amazing but kg is
long gone oh yeah was that the one that
used to travel with on the road yeah and
he was my baby I feel like a mom who's
like I don't know what happened to him
he got involved with drugs and he used I
used to be his everything he would
cuddle with me for hours like I
understand that now you have to let him
go no you still friends a Sara Schaefer
yeah yeah you guys cuz that's I first
met you when you guys are doing your MTV
show together yes and you came on it yes
my first TV thing ever so it was super
fun I just was like these girls are
doing something really [ __ ] cool yeah
that was cool yeah it was the Nikki and
Sara show right yeah Nikki and Sara live
on MTV yeah we did two seasons of it was
like a yeah I don't know what it was a
variety show like we did
yeah pop-culture variety yeah yeah we
did sketch we did a lot of
man-on-the-street stuff we did
interviews and we did like kind of
weekend update' style jokes yeah you
guys got surprised with Justin
Timberlake surprised us yeah we thought
we were going to Vegas to interview
Ke$ha and we were waiting in this room
and she's late and we're like we had
already interviewed her we were like
this isn't even like that I make a video
like it was still caching so we like
cared obviously but right and
we're just sitting there and she was
late and I was like I can't believe
Ke$ha like I still have a little grudge
with her because she was so late that
day that she wasn't booked and they were
lying to us so sorry Ke$ha and so lead
you in my mind forever but then Justin
Timberlake tinted we were just like what
is happening it was because we were
that's like what kind of who brought us
together because we met at a party and
we're talking about Justin temple really
it was like someone's to know and I
think this can relate to dancer the
stars
what is a good way to get yourself to do
something that you're totally afraid to
do just think about what's the worst
that can happen and then if you and then
it's probably gonna be better than that
but I will say that what happened to me
on Dancing with the Stars was the worst
that could happen the worst thing that
can happen will not happen it's more
than likely it won't happen like the
worst thing but then sometimes it does
this will be the worst outcome that I
imagine that isn't supposed to happen it
did even when it does you still are okay
no one cares and no one thinks about you
as much as you think about yourself so
just take a chance and like don't but
that you only have one life to live I
don't know all these stupid platitudes
but it's all that stuff combined and at
the end of the day you have a story yes
I got a story and I was doing something
I would have regretted not doing it I
couldn't have I would have always been
like I can't believe I could have done
Dancing with the Stars and I didn't and
I just imagined myself I imagined myself
in the future being a woman who's okay
enough with herself physically and like
emotionally to be like see the stars
that's fun like if I am gonna be there
eventually and that's the kind of woman
I want to be why not do it now ya know
and also do you think that this is
opened you up to now when new things
come your way you're way more
open-minded about them I can do anything
I really can do anything cuz that show
was my biggest fear yeah I mean there's
nothing I can't if I can do Dancing I
did American Ninja Warrior - you did
celebrity American Ninja Warrior when
was this they asked me like the day
before cuz they had a drop out and I was
like okay so I did it because I was the
same thing I was like I'm gonna be
terrible thing I'm gonna be the worst
and I was the worst I got really injured
it was like the same before it was weird
enough before I did that shows but I
would not do dancing with stars oh my
god it was so bad
so my yeah I did the worst by far by
four was the worst but I ended up I
wanted to quit I got there and I was
like I don't want to do this I'm not
doing this I'm holding out like I'm
quitting and I only signed on to it a
couple days ago so it's not like they
really and they're like it's for charity
and I'm like God fine I'll do it like
there's it's and so I did it and it was
I got so injured it was great because
that was like my first time for a and
doing something that was so out of my
comfort zone and I'm just an ability TV
program game yeah that you trying to get
in with the networks being like I can
hang with you guys having a showing and
um but then I was now I really felt like
I gave it a speech like I was with all
the cast of Dancing with the Stars most
of the cast at the first night that we
all would the night before Good Morning
America wouldn't we announced it we all
like a lot of us went to this dinner
afterwards and we were all just kind of
like making like announcements having a
great time and I was like I just want to
say that because of tomorrow's
announcements doing the show like I
literally can do anything now like and I
and I mention that the the moment I was
like I could have a threesome like I
could finally have a threesome I've
always been scared of having a threesome
and I know that that's not the next
logical step but like I've I want to I
want the story cuz that's what there's
no better story than a threesome like
sex stories are the stories yeah and a
threesome story it's like it's a
question that gets asked line I'm always
like never had a threesome moving on to
the next uestion I want one and I've
never and I don't really want when it
scares me like because we can manifest
it like it's not even like it's I could
have one
okay whatever draggable now I could have
one tonight yeah I mean but I don't but
I'm scared to have one but if it ever
presents itself if ABC calls and says
we're doing a new show
yeah I'll do anything
look I can do anything now all the
things that scare me that I'm like yeah
maybe I could do a threesome someday but
I wouldn't now I'm like I'll do it when
it when make him come calling what
doesn't kill you makes you a veil I
don't know why I'm like that's like my
biggest like fear but also like dancing
in a threesome yes well I think this
year you can accomplish everything and
we've reached the end of the podcast
Niki thank you for being here but before
you go we give everyone a personalized
fortune cookie for me just making time
for us my gosh thank you so much
of course I honestly do not remember at
all with your throwbacks are very
inspirational and remind us to be more
vulnerable on platforms that conditioned
us to put our fake best foot forward you
were also the first person to receive a
sincere fortune we feel gross now Niki
where can people find you if they don't
know where can they see you coming up I
have a daily morning show on Sirius
radio so if you have serious or a rental
car that's Monday through Thursday 10:00
to 12:00 Eastern but we also have a
podcast of the Sirius show that's like
the best of class out every Friday you
up podcast it's really fun you go
through like every day and you give like
a little segment that was like the most
funny anecdote yeah it's really today
thank you and then I'm at Nikki Glaser
on on all socials and then I'm on tour
right now and you can find all my dates
at Nikki Glaser comm suite and also
follow our instagram story because yes
it's one for thank you for the hooks
yeah that means a lot to me you know so
much so don't mind if I'm the one that's
talking more than your crush flattered
you watch I can't even stand it deep
deep deep deep not too deep as a
production of grace Helbig incorporated
a producer and directed by Jack ferry
producer and editor
Melissa demons writing by Diane King
post production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]